We now continue with
our example and turn
to the performance
evaluation question.
As you recall, we
have a Theta that
has a certain
prior distribution.
We're given a model
for the observations.
We came up with the joint
distribution for X and Theta,
which was uniform on
this particular shape,
and we found that the
least mean squares
estimator, namely the
conditional expectation
of Theta given any
particular value of X,
is given by this particular
piecewise linear function.
Now, let us look at the
performance of this estimator.
We judge the performance given
any particular value of X
by looking at the corresponding
mean squared error, which
is the square of the distance
between the unknown parameter
and the estimate with
which we came up.
And as we have discussed,
this is the same
as the variance of Theta but
in the conditional universe
where X has been observed.
It's the variance of the
conditional distribution
of Theta.
As we have discussed,
if I tell you
that X takes on this
particular value,
Theta is uniform
on this interval.
Therefore, the conditional
variance of Theta
is the variance of a
uniform on an interval
of this particular length.
Now, we know that the
variance of a uniform
on an interval from a to b
is equal to b minus a squared
divided by 12.
In this particular instance,
the interval has length 2.
Therefore, we have 2
squared divided by 12.
So the variance is equal to 1/3.
This is what we get when
the picture is of this type.
On the other hand, if X
falls in this range, then
this interval on which Theta
is now constrained to live,
has a smaller length
and we're going
to get a different variance.
So in order to keep track,
let us come up with a plot.
When X is between 5 and 9, Theta
has a conditional distribution
which is uniform on an
interval of length 2
and a variance of 1/3.
And therefore, the variance
is constant, takes this value.
In the extreme case,
when X is equal to 3,
then this interval has 0 length.
In fact, we have
perfect certainty
about the value of Theta.
If X is equal to 3, then we
know that Theta is equal to 4.
There's no uncertainty.
There's zero variance.
What happens in between?
As we increase x
moving away from 3,
the length of this interval
increases linearly with x.
And this means that the
variance increases quadratically
with x, so we have a
quadratic that starts at 0
and rises to this value.
And by a symmetric
argument, on the other side,
we also get function,
which is 0 at 11,
and which rises quadratically
as x gets reduced from 11 to 9.
So this is a complete plot
of the conditional variance
of Theta as a function of
the particular observation
that we have obtained.
We notice that some x's are
more favorable than others.
An observation equal to
3 is extremely favorable
because it tells
us unambiguously
the value of Theta.
But other choices of x,
other possible observations,
will lead to more
uncertainty in Theta,
and this is reflected
in this diagram.
In case we are now interested in
the overall mean squared error,
then we have to
calculate the average
of this conditional variance
where the average is taken over
all values of X.
This is going to be
an integral of the conditional
variance of Theta integrated
over all possibilities for x.
But, of course, each
possibility of x
has to be weighted according to
the corresponding probability,
or in this case, probability
density function of X.
What is the PDF of X?
It is not a given
to us, but it is
something that can
be easily determined
from what we have already done.
We know the joint
distribution of Theta and X,
and whenever we know the joint
we can also find the marginal.
So once we find the
marginal PDF of X,
then we can plug it in,
multiply by this function
that we have already obtained,
carry out the integration,
and we will end up
with a numerical value.
Since it is an average
of what we have here,
it's going to end up being
some number between 0 and 1/3.
It's the average of these
values, and closer to 1/3
rather than 0.
And this would complete
the way that a performance
of a particular
estimator gets evaluated.